je m'appelle alice longtemps j'ai 38 ans
un boulot de rêve une fille formidable
pas de mec et pour tout vous dire j'ai
jamais été aussi heureuse de ma vie
[Musique]
spider salle e mail oui je comprends pas
je crois que c'était la scène ont quitté
confiance pour apprendre le magazine la
merde qu'est ce qu'elle en plus comment
tu fais pas relevé
comment tu veux faire rêver les actrices
très bien dire que je suis trop vieille
à l'image la caisse qui débite sol mais
ça vaut quoi vous m'avez laisse un
message vous allez trouver la clé usb
c'est ça le principe c'est que je
m'entends tu es bon tu perds ça twitter
diane vincent parce que tu crois ce
genre de choses sur la photo tu me fait
rêver
un tel esprit rebelle john togo ce
concert quasi va faire part que tu es de
l'étape
nuance
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on fait là j'avais perdu
ton amber en fait et je me suis le plus
simple est encore de passer carrément
souviens que j'avais tournage j'avais
rencontré une calabraise corded web et
surtout avec deux fois mon avis je suis
désolé pour l'été des investisseurs un
gars morts 19 ans matt hazard ça 10
novembre
je sais ce que vous devez vous dire il
est jeune fils envie de déconner se la
raconter devant ses pattes mais c'est
pas du tout ça lui plaisait vraiment je
veux dire vraiment comme s'est jamais
arrivé avant au niveau et regarder dans
la presse et du jardin
[Musique]